Hó hẳng tiền Rồi Tư s, ngoại trường ngà sư gay là VLOG trường rằng Mỹ đang tìm cách kiểm soát thì thống đường ông giống khi NOS 3, nhằm ra các ngày hưởng chỉ đi trường năng lượng toàn tâu.
Pháp yếu đưa ra trường bối cảnh chân cả ý xung quanh vụ nổ phán hoại đường ông giúp hiện bắn tinh năm 2018, vẫn chưa có kết lận quý cộng.
Ông Lạ VLOG không cung cấp bằng chứng của thế, sau nhận định Washington đã mở giọng phai trò tại các khu bực dầu tàng quanh.
Đồng thời quan tâm đến hạ tình năng lượng trị lượng của châu Âu.
Chuy đó, mất số 1 tinh phương tây cho biết khó nhà đồ tương Mỹ, bày tỏ quan tâm đến việc mua lại một phần dự á NOS 3.
Hẹt Hó NOS 3 từng là tuyến cùng cấp khi đối quan trọng từng á săng châu Âu.
Nhưng đã bị hòa nghiêm chào, sau các vụ nổ năng hành hình thung chà mẹi, khiến hồn cung bị giám đại.
Các bây linh quan bà của nha và phương tây đều có đe là hành bí phá hoại và tính hành điều tra trong một thời sáng xanh.
Châu khi đó, châu Âu đã nấu lực đa giọng hã hồn cung năng lượng, nha mạng phụ thuộc vào khi đúng nha.
Các truy ra nhìn định cạnh trang đề chính trị về năng lượng tinh tục giá tăng.
Châu khi những cám buộc qua lại có thể là mất tạp thêm tình hình.